what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
you what I see in you you'll be able to
change the planet and so to help you on
your journey I started to believe love
series to try to help entrepreneurs with
their relationships because running a
business is really hard and management
relationship is hard enough normally now
inject entrepreneurship at the same time
it could really difficult we've run a
couple in the series and unfortunately
this is going to be the last one in the
series because it didn't have the impact
that I was looking for so we're going to
be looking to introduce a couple new
series ideas but we have this one last
one just for you guys it's advice from
sage and Tony Robbins on the five
disciplines of love enjoy this is your
checklist for the rest of your life if
something's not working in your
relationship this is the first place you
go five disciplines of love and three of
passion these five disciplines are what
the game is all about the first
discipline we call the discipline of
unconditional love and compassion the
discipline what we'll call it discipline
because you don't always feel
unconditionally loving you're always
feel compassionate if your triggers get
fired if something triggers your
masculine or feminine you know animal in
you that's survival instinct in you
based on something going on you may not
show up so you know unconditional in
your love and compassion what this
really means put it one phrase put your
lover what it's not about you that's the
law you put your lover first if you are
having problems in your relationship I
can promise you that the problem you're
having right now is you're feeling pain
right now and it's because you're
focused on yourself not your partner
your focus on what you're not getting
your focus on what your partner's not
giving you your focus on something
that's not happening there this is the
number one blog you want to have an
extraordinary relationship tear up your
rules make this your number one rule
number one rule is my lever comes first
my number one rule is if you love you
put their feelings and needs before your
own
second discipline real quick the
discipline of absolute courage and
vulnerability absolute courage and
vulnerability this is learning to love
no matter what I mean truly no matter
what now how many people are going to do
that not many not many people are going
to extraordinary relationship but what I
mean by this is if you have courage and
vulnerability that means you tell the
truth that means you open up most people
out of a lack of courage hold back their
gift this idea that you're going to give
pain to somebody you love you're going
to punish them that takes no courage
that takes no vulnerability that's just
stupidity so the more global you are the
more power you have because love
penetrates all third law so all positive
content the discipline I should say a
positive intent by the way discipline
weighs ounces regret weighs tons
discipline weighs ounces or grant weighs
tons you don't follow these disciplines
you're going to regret
alright that's their disciplines their
commitments their things you're going to
do no matter what this Allah means even
if it's not easy you still do it right
discipline is it's a habit that's what a
discipline is it's a habit so discipline
a positive intent
you know the deeper truth that this is a
no blame game you know that when
something happens no matter what it was
like when I said that to her my girl
knew she and I made a decision early on
I decided and this decision I encouraged
you to make up you haven't made it or
make it anew if you haven't made it in
years I decided I knew this woman's soul
this woman's soul was as pure as
anything I could ever dream of in my
life I knew that I loved this woman her
soul is pure so man what happened I
would serve her and I'm gonna what
happened what she said about what she
did I would know even if I couldn't
figure out how the intent was pure the
intent was one to get closer it looks
mean but she's scared
it looks vicious but she's just freaked
out you know and same thing with me he
looks like he's an unconscious [ __ ]
he just doesn't know it looks like he
doesn't give us he's actually a
masculine male and this is what they do
right we shifted the meaning to always
there's an empowering meaning because
there's never negative intent no matter
what it looks like no matter what was
said and by having that along with
this one opossum camp instead snow
playing game we immediately apologize it
doesn't matter what caused happened if
there's any argument we have it's a
playful argument which is I'm taking
responsibility and she take
responsibility was my fault that was my
fault and it's like and we mean it
sincerely it doesn't matter what it is
because I hold myself is whatever she's
feeling ultimately it's my
responsibility even if I didn't intended
that's it so I take responsibility I'm
sorry honey I'm sorry if things were she
does it with me also and since we both
are constantly doing it it makes it like
there's nobody ever blaming somebody
else so think about this we put each
other first we find we're not we change
that immediately right we immediately
look at we got to be courage and
vulnerable you've got to tell the truth
that's really worth it is tell the truth
with kindness with love with making
nobody wrong because we both know we are
positive again and you way too old a
bowl with it mm-hmm and with an apology
rather than I'm sorry
you always have I yes always I hon I'm
sorry today when I upset you or I'm
sorry today if I upset you having the
word I am owning it neutralized such a
crazy and we so underrate and apology of
ownership owning something who cares
when you love each other who cares about
being right or wrong and if there really
is an unconscious action and even if it
wasn't your intent even if it wasn't
unconscious even if it was a
misinterpretation who cares
own it you own it and it neutralizes
that and it only like brings you closer
it's extraordinary
and you got to remember no matter what
they did that's not who they are if you
can remember that human behavior is not
a reflection of the human spirit often
its respective reflex action of the
animal inside of us and if you can know
that you know their spirit you know
their soul then you know when people get
insecure when they get uncertain when
they go on survival I've done it you've
done it we've all done it so instead of
judging and making them wrong because
you're scared of being hurt again you
got to come back to I know what their
intent is I know it's positive and you
crushed my intent you end the
relationship you questioned my behavior
you got to be right to do that even if I
disagree with you you just never
question can i underline that I bold it
I go on if you question intent you are
destroying the relationship
so you look at somebody usually you
subscribe either what you would do or if
you dislike something about them or
you're in a down State
you'll come up with the worst reason why
they did it it's never the truth they
did it to meet some needs same as you
but underneath that if you know their
soul you just don't question their
intent now think of it you just did
these three things what would be
destroyed on your list oh my god our
kids webinar wait a second my wife comes
first by us and comes first
you know what bottom line is I trust and
love them where these kids are going to
be great I'm gonna bend I'm gonna find
something here for him I want to find
something here for her right I'm gonna
and I'm making it so crazy I'm being up
so upset what am I really upset about
I'm upset thinking my kids are not going
to be the way I want them to do not my
kids are going to be the way they're
meant to be so it's really about me
again right you know just for the
absolute curse you know honey I just
wanna talk to you I'm concerned this is
how I was raised I know you were raised
differently vulnerably I love you I love
you the way you are you're a rebel you
love me I have rules maybe our kids will
be okay with that tear what do you think
finding someone you know knowing that
there's positive intent will kill any
anger upset inside this peace forth one
of the five disciplines fourth is a
discipline of honorable language and
moment-to-moment awareness honorable
language there is power in love
adoration and praise and most of us
don't use it enough most of us don't
praise enough
and when I say praise make a note if
you're going to praise your man or your
woman you must praise them specifically
not generally but moment-to-moment being
consciously aware of the impact the
impact that you're having with your
language and your presence on your
partner and your language as well body
language words deeds it's knowing you
have an insight and seeing that impact
you know if I'm doing something and I
look over and I see my girl is not a
great place I don't continue so what
happens for a woman to understand is we
get information into your word words go
into that file in our brain well temas
fear emotions go on the other side
but when you say a word to a woman it
hits both hemispheres it's like if I
asked you where are you on you know the
11th of August in 2001 but if I ask you
where were you on 9/11 coming member
exactly where you were in the room when
you heard about it or you were there you
saw it because information with emotion
is remembered forever and for women
words that you say I mean a lot because
they had to turn when she's pleasing you
or not and those words get connected to
emotion and you might just be saying
things because guys say things all the
time right and when you're that upset
men gentlemen there's nowhere to go
you're never going to hurt that woman in
a million years so the only way to let
go so the pressure is yell or scream or
use some words but then she takes those
words in and she's hurt by and hears it
here's a trip I'm married to a very
passionate man who's married to
certainly a very passionate woman and
little you know we made decisions I
never I hate you never I'm going to
leave you and not ask you telling will
say SSS now there's like I mean it can
come flying out of his mouth and have
such a level of intensity but for s sake
cube could you could you whatever that
might be is different than ever to you
that and one other big one I'll give you
is if you ever threaten the end of the
relationship end it because if you ever
threaten it when people go to put their
button on the tail on the button you
know just a threatening because they're
so frustrated the moment you do that
somewhere in the psyche of your partner
they think oh my god they can leave me
and I'm I gotta have to do this first
and so they put their finger on the
button and all it takes is enough times
of doing that enough years of doing that
and one day somebody push the button if
you are committed to the relationship
you're in banned for life for multiple
lifetimes for those you're going to come
back six and seven times like some of
the people here did you ban for multiple
lifetimes I will never ever ever
threaten never night of you ever
threatens to leave if you threaten to
leave relationships over might take
three more years five more ten years but
it's over if you want to be in a
relationship with this person don't ever
ever ever threaten if you did before
it's off-limits forever no it's
I'm not mad you are angry or sad you are
never you're not unconscious for your
language and unconscious with your deeds
you're aware of the impact and you
correct it immediately
you constantly realize I'm pissed off
I'm hurt I'm sad it's about me let me
step out of me I'm going to something
bigger here right this is I'm not about
them about something bigger it's what do
they need let me step to me you do that
enough times it'll become a habit then
finally number five the discipline of
giving freedom giving freedom men live
for freedom women need it also but it
comes in different forms and it's the
power of forgiving forgetting and
flooding forgiving forgetting and
flooding now women seem to have more of
a difficulty with forgetting but you can
be forgiving and forgiveness is when you
realize that what you thought happened
didn't really happen you gave it a
meaning that doesn't really match
reality you're expecting your partner to
be something different than they are
flooding is one of most valuable skills
you can do in your life if you don't
flood you'll have a hard time forgiving
and forgetting and we flood our magic
moments I mean olds are all the time and
we capture them you know we have our
little app with journal that we capture
all of our just our beautiful moments
after this event when we get home on
Sunday we'll spend an hour and just
capture all the beautiful moments that
happen here everything that was funny
everything that was beautiful everything
that was touching because otherwise it's
just it's actually what Nicole was
talking about maybe she talked about
framing you have a peak experience and
you actually give words to it and that
frames it and it helps to get to that
place it's just like you bypass all that
effort that took you there and the
Masters next starting point and then you
have another peak experience and then
you share that new frame it you give
language and you give words to it and
then boom you set the hot the bar higher
and a lot of times what happens is we
magic happens in life grace pours and we
don't give words till we don't celebrate
it we don't recognize it we don't see it
we don't appreciate it in putting words
to that of appreciation and of selling
and reliving and experiencing it it is
it is I would say it's one of the top 10
things for us that we do that just it
nice and that feeling and just of utter
appreciation we always capture it so we
go back and read it it's so beautiful
this is this is okay this is something
to share so when we first it's clear he
was so ahh oh my gosh
like I mean rigid militant flu like so
intense about these things and so I mean
anytime that anybody would talk about
eggs he was just like in did what felt
like he was not vicious but it felt like
that level of intensity and so we were
together and I was feeling like I needed
more protein and we share everything and
it was so crazy because I started to eat
eggs and I literally and I ain't got no
this doesn't tells us but I did not tell
him and I felt like I was having a
frickin affair with an egg and I was
literally I would go into the pantry and
I'd eat the eggs and I'm like this is
nuts like this is just this is crazy it
seems ridiculous and it sounds nutty but
what was again I put so much energy into
hiding my egg eating and and then
exactly the same I was like this is this
is outrageous this is just out of hand
and I sat down was she funny camera on
each of them shared with the affairs of
another item he does go animal he does
and I still eat them again I really I
love breakfast I love my eggs and I love
my bread I love her so I love an egg
eater now you know the truth yeah so we
disagree completely but we love each
other so that's how you balance it out
you get it you get it you put love first
you love more than your rules mm-hmm and
it makes you a better human being
because it opens you up because lots of
things were making life and death that
really hard really hard thank you guys
so much for watching I hope you enjoyed
I'd love to know what did you think of
this video is there something that
you're going to immediately apply
somehow to your life after watching it
and again thank you for joining me on
the believe love series it was a fun
ride while it lasted
you can go back and watch the other
videos in the series
and it says that it's over but I'm
looking forward to bringing you
something new as a test experiment to
see what you think
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love see you soon